un simple barrio convertido en epicentro
de un conflicto de dimensiones
internacionales
sheikh jarrah es un distrito palestino
en la ocupada jerusalén este una zona
que a su vez tiene una importancia
religiosa para los judios albergando la
tumba de simón primero el justo un
prominente sacerdote situado al norte de
la ciudad vieja de jerusalén este punto
ya ha empezado a recibir nuevos
asentamientos israelíes frente a una
comunidad palestina que teme ser
desahuciada en octubre una primera
sentencia de la justicia israelí falló
en favor de los judios que reclaman que
esta tierra es suya desde antes de 1948
y para denunciar al mundo ese temor a
perder sus hogares muchos han optado por
las redes sociales
la campaña de salvar a sheikh jarrah
comenzó con los residentes y es una
campaña clara y directa contra la
política de desahucios por parte de las
autoridades de ocupación de israel en 6
guerra y también en jerusalén y en toda
la palestina histórica
es precisamente a través de las redes
que se divulgan con transmisiones en
vivo los enfrentamientos que transcurren
con las fuerzas de seguridad en la
actual escalada de violencia les
mostramos lo que está ocurriendo a quién
se guiará específicamente en jerusalén y
en palestina en general
intentamos grabar las escenas que tienen
lugar cada día tales como las
violaciones de nuestros derechos humanos
las comunidades palestinas apelaron ante
la corte suprema de israel el fallo en
favor de los judíos la semana pasada
este tribunal aplazó para comienzos de
junio una audiencia sobre esos
desahucios de las familias palestinas la
sentencia al final de este caso amenaza
con ser un punto de giro en medio de un
contexto ya con muchas atenciones